make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are continuing
our dawn of x
coverage yes we are and in this video we
are picking up with excalibur
here's the cool thing about this right
here's the cool thing about this this is
really going to kind of
allow us a chance to offer some pretty
cool explanations
insofar as how the cabin britain core
works jonathan hickman's avengers and
new avengers the collapse of the
multiverse how all that stuff ties
into what's going on right now with his
x-men run this is why i
always tell people if you want to read
jonathan hickman's work
read it by itself do not read anything
else unless you absolutely
have to this is an example of where you
kind of have to right because other
people are writing the swords of x story
as opposed to just jonathan hickman and
it all basically ties together but you
can literally just read hickman by
himself
and read nothing else and just maybe
catch up on a couple things here and
there
but the cool thing here is it offered it
allows us a bit of an explanation but
before we get to that point we pick up
with the arrival of jamie braddock and
brian braddock as they've been summoned
by saturnine and the whole idea is that
as they're meeting uh
betsy braddock here right as we're
meeting you know captain brittany here
once they arrive
things get pretty murky pretty fast and
the reason why is because as brian
braddock shows up here
betsy realizes he's in possession of the
sword of might and when she asks why is
that here his response is because i
brought it for you
and the the idea of brian braddock is to
basically switch these things right for
brian to retake the amulet and for
for betty for betsy to take the sword of
might now here's the reason why that
matters because once all that passes and
they're basically met by the arrival of
saturnine that she's assembled them here
and
it looks like it's basically a kind of
giant get-together to honor the fallen
captain written core that existed before
the events of hickman's avengers and new
avengers but the idea is that this kind
of argument is taking place in such a
way to where
brian wants things to go back to the way
they were before that one of the things
that saturday talks about is the fall of
the captain britain court now the way
this worked was the result of hikman's
avengers and new avengers right so the
captain written core in previous years
was largely created by merlin and then
roma and a combination of both and the
way this would play out is that in any
one
universe on any one earth out there that
what you would have is some individual
who would be met at some point in time
by merlin or roma
or both and what they would do is they
would present them with an option they
would say you have the choice
of the sword of might or the amulet of
right there wasn't really a wrong answer
there but whichever one they took they
would go forward with those
corresponding powers and they would in
effect become
the captain britain of their universe
and the idea is that the captain britain
of that universe would serve to protect
that universe but also serve as part of
a larger whole they would protect the
multiverse alongside other captain
britain members and so think of it as a
more localized version of like i'm sorry
a much larger version of the green
lantern core
and so the result of this is that during
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers as we covered with that story
that there came a point where
saturnine and the omniversal development
court were trying to understand
why the multiverse was collapsing why
they didn't fully understand it and so
what they ended up doing was getting
their hands on a map maker with a desire
to effectively crack the map maker
understand its code and then
get it get a bigger picture the problem
with this was that the map maker ended
up summoning its own forces right and it
really was more of a sadera madrid
as opposed to a map maker but they ended
up summoning the forces of both the
ivory kings and the ivory king soldiers
and this led to the complete and total
annihilation of the captain britain
court the only
person who survived was brian braddock
and brian braddock only survived because
saturnine took all the knowledge of the
starlight citadel right so all
information containing the existence of
the multiverse and
everything that she knew about the
multiverse and literally used telepathy
to put in the mind of ryan braddock and
then cast him out right and he basically
ended up showing back up to the
illuminati at some point in time but
that's how the captain written core fell
now following the restoration of the
multiverse the cap of written core was
not restored the reason for that is
because the method and manner of
choosing the captain britton core is not
arbitrary the sword of might
or the amulet of right and in years past
this is kind of what saturnine says here
in years past
captain britons who were chosen for that
particular role had to undergo that test
what we're told here is there are
captain britons out there in the
multiverse but saturnine considers them
to be heretical she considers them to be
to be heretics because they have not
undergone the process of choosing
between the sword or the amulet and so
because they have not undergone that
traditional process they're not
real captain britain's for all intents
and purposes the way that saturn views
it somebody just grabbed a captain
britain uniform slapped it on and now
they're that character right they're not
the rightful character they haven't
undergone the process a person should
undergo in order to become that in order
to overtake that role and so because of
that while there are captain britain's
there she's basically captured them and
she's holding them until she decides
when they're ready to be destroyed and
so in this frustration and this
irritation as far as
as saturnine is concerned while brian
braddock is not in possession of the
amulet he is in possession of the of the
sword and brian braddock
is the only true captain britain that
betsy braddock is not that bessie
braddock is considered to be a heretic
in the eyes of saturnine and this really
is kind of doubled down by betsy's own
admission when saturnine makes the case
about the sword and the amulet and betsy
says i never had to make either choice
and that's when saturday's like those
are your words not mine in effect in the
eyes of saturnine betsy braddock doomed
herself and she basically gave saturnine
license to take her captive right and
that's what she kind of says like the
exit's that way right you don't need to
be here like there's no reason for you
to be here now as she goes to kind of
make her way she's met by brian and the
crazy thing about this
is that she kind of challenges brian to
a fight right she's like let's get this
on right let's let's let's figure this
out once and for all like who
is the actual captain britain the cool
thing about this and what's interesting
here
is that brian's response is i gave you
the amulet if you guys remember
the excalibur story the first one that
we did his response was i gave you the
amulet because i was being taken over
by morgan le fay in this moment when i
was basically being transformed into her
henchmen i did not want her to have a
henchman that had the power of the
amulet so i gave it to you but this was
only ever meant to be temporary that
ultimately i knew that you guys would
win against morgan le faye and when that
time came i hoped that you would give
the amulet back to me that's why i gave
you this sword the response of betsy is
i don't want to give it back to you
right i like being captain britain i
want to stay captain britain like the
whole idea of
of brian braddock is but you don't even
live in england like you live in krakowa
you live in a whole different place what
kind of captain britain could you
possibly be if you don't even live in
the place you represent right it doesn't
really make any sense it's like a
president of the united states that
lives in japan it's
nonsensical there's no it just it just
doesn't work that way right now at this
point it's really just kind of arguing
geographic location but
if we're being honest with ourselves
because a captain britain
can become that way by taking the sword
or the amulet then we're really just
kind of arguing semantics
it's really what's happening here that's
all this is coming down to but the funny
thing about this is that as they kind of
begin to get into a little bit of their
fight
betsy braddock does make a really good
point in saying that becoming captain
britain is an honor it's not a
birthright right you're not owed this
you're not owed the role of captain
britain despite what the lineage is and
despite your ties to king arthur you're
not owed this role you had this role
bestowed upon you at one point in time
but it could also have been taken away
and if they can be taken away from you
then it's not a thing that you
inherently own right it's a thing that's
just given to you
for some temporary amount of time even
if that temporary amount of time
just happens to be your entire life it
can be taken away at any point in time
and so what you end up doing here is you
kind of have this this whole situation
that's kind of interrupted
right by by saturnine you know and she's
like you guys need to calm down but the
funny thing about this is she kind of
seems to be sewing discord among the two
right like she kind of seems to be
creating a rift among these two now what
we end up doing
is picking up later that night and when
that happens you end up having
uh having you know jamie jamie braddock
who's kind of sleeping you know in his
guest quarters and is met
by what are what's essentially an
assemblage of captain britain's that are
different other different characters
based on the x-men right so
rogue who's a captain britain gambit
who's a captain britain jubilee that
kind of a thing and so the result of
this is that they basically say like we
sentence you to die
right now the motivation for why they
sentence him to die we're not really
given a definitive explanation here
instead
what is up happening and and it kind of
looks as though jamie may have sold them
out but
but what it looks like happened here or
at least what does happen here is you
have betsy and you have brian who of
course respond
and then once they get in there jamie's
got all these guys seized right now
again
jamie brad can warp reality on a
universal scale and that's what those
strings are right those strings that
emanate that's
that's how it is that he controls
reality now this is just kind of shown
to us for artistic license
it's just kind of shown to us like this
is what he's actually doing in terms of
how it is that like betsy and brian or
brian braddock see it he's just standing
there and they're floating in thin air
and all hell's popping loose right
that's that's all it kind of looks to
them this is just kind of shown so that
we can get an artistic understanding of
how his powers work
but the whole point behind this is he's
kind of like okay they showed up here
with the intention of killing me i can't
just let that slide but
you know if i can't kill them all then
i'll just kill one to help them
understand their place in the bigger
picture and so in doing that he kills
the captain britain jubilee right he
kills the jubilee version of captain
britain and so once she's dead
it pisses off all the others right they
go after them and they end up taking off
right they end up basically bailing out
brian braddock ultimately ends up
drawing the sword of might from the
scabbard and when he does
he becomes a version of captain britain
using the sword of might
right now at that moment he in turn
turns it on the rest of the captain
britain core and says
i will strike you down if i have to i
don't want to but i will kill you if i
have to but
that's when saturnine steps in and so
she basically she she kind of
appeals to brian braddock right with
this idea kind of kind of
appealing to his his manly nature right
being a little romantic and and so on
and saying like you know get rid of this
sword of my you don't need this anymore
right i am the sole
occupant of the starlight citadel merlin
and roma are long dead
i determine who's going to be the
captain britain from this point going
forward and so she basically tells him
get rid of the sword she tries to strip
the amulet away from betsy braddock with
the intention of giving it to brian but
betsy uses a combination of her
of her power along with some spells that
she learned from apocalypse and destroys
the amulet in the process
now the reason why this matters is
because the amulet is what gives cat
though that version of captain britain
their power right so like flight force
field different things like that suit
you know enhanced strength super speed
so on and so forth without the amulet
those powers can't freely be given right
it would have to be restored or
something along those lines
as a result of that she ends up having
betsy brady taken away and takes ryan to
what is basically her bed chamber and so
as a result of this
you've hit pick up with with betsy
braddock right kind of down this this
holding cell and she kind of tries to
reach out so far she hasn't really been
successful but she tries to reach out
and is ultimately met by the gambit
version of captain britain from
from whatever alternate reality that
happens to be and what she basically
says is
at least having this conversation with
him she asks like you know are you guys
okay
right is everything okay and the the
funny thing is like she tells them like
we'll try it like i'm gonna try to find
a way out but what she's told by gambit
is escaping the cells is no small thing
if all he had to do is pick a lock and
leave it wouldn't really be much of a
prison cell
and so what he tells her is there are
spells that surround this cell and the
way in which it works is that when rogue
tried to break out she literally just
tried to fly out of it and got
exceedingly cold and she can't get any
warm now right like she got cold she got
lost
and she can't warm up right so there's
an effect that it has on you it's that
kind of magic
that keeps people contained within these
cells and so what ends up happening is
that while she's telepathically
communicating with gambit that jimmy
braddock piggybacks onto their their
communications right and says okay so
like you need to jump out jump out the
window now and i will catch you
i mean they're so high up that if you
were to jump out you'd probably end up
getting yourself killed when you hit the
ground uh and the fact that she doesn't
really have the amulet means her normal
powers or the powers of captain britain
aren't ready readily available to her
now
you could kind of ask the question if
she really is that powerful in terms of
her telekinesis why couldn't she just
fly that's a good question to ask
i don't know why we don't get an answer
to that but it kind of seems to be this
sort of revolving spell that exists
right
like if she jumps out the window then
she gets caught up in the spell and so
the response to this of of jamie
braddock is okay you could stay here but
keep in mind you're in other world and
they're gonna execute you at dawn so
when you die like if you die or
when the time comes if you're executed
and you die they can bring you back on
gracoa but remember guys if you die in
other world and they resurrect you in
krakowa you come back
all screwed up right you come back all
twisted and screwed up we saw that in
the last couple videos that we made
that's one of the important points about
dying in other world that remains for
the rest of swords of x
if you die out there there's no
guarantee that the version of you that
comes back will be the person who died
it could be any other alternate reality
version of yourself right so maybe
betsy braddock jumps out and or she's
executed in the morning and curcuma
resurrects her and she comes back
it's like some crazy some absolutely
nuts girl who's held in on world
domination right there's no way of
knowing if that's going to be the case
right no way of knowing what version of
her will come back and so because of
that you end up having her of course
making this leap of faith out the window
and then being caught by a griffin right
that belongs to uh to jamie brodic who
of course rescues her and the two of
them make their way towards saturnine's
bed chamber and as she's there what she
ends up doing is basically telling brian
braddock you're the one that needs to
represent this prophecy right you're the
one that needs to
to basically wield this starlight sword
not betsy braddock she's not a real
captain britain this has to be you
you have to be the one to to wield this
weapon and so what she ends up doing is
basically
crafting the starlight sword itself now
one of the things to keep in mind here
and this is something that we we may not
have really covered or hadn't been too
clear on
is that this whole idea that of course
you know once betsy braddock and then
show up you know and like literally you
have saturday making out with brian
braddock right so you know like let's
let's touch naughty bits right you have
like uh you have you know bet siri and
you have uh jamie who are kind of
watching everything go down and then
brian braddock realizes she's there and
he's like betsy take the sword now right
betsy runs in grabs a sword and we
realized that brian braddock was never
actually on the side of saturnine but he
was basically playing her in order to
give betsy time to steal the starlight
sword herself because that's part of the
prophecy for the swords of x event one
of the things to understand here is this
prophecy is not something that predates
saturnine right it's not as though it's
a prophecy that's been around for like
millennia and it's just now coming to
fruition this is a game that saturnine
herself created right she created the
prophecy she created all of this
right it's kind of her great big huge
game to just sort of see what happens we
don't really know what the end result of
this is we don't really know
what it is that she's trying to achieve
what's the point of standing in the way
of the forces of
of morocco that want to invade the main
marvel universe and kill everybody there
what's the point of that right if you're
in the starlight citadel what's the
whole point i mean you're not really
affected by any of it so why does it
matter to you right we don't really know
what the end result of her whole
campaign is what we do know
is this kind of of effort between brian
and and betty has ultimately worked that
what it's done
is this drove saturday to create the
starlight sword which was the missing
weapon that they needed in order to
secure the forces of earth fighting
against the forces of morocco and so now
they have both they have the sword of
might and they have the starlight sword
and so it solidifies
this position right and so from here it
just boils down to three more swords
right all we have are three more
my question here and this is the
question that i feel like a lot of you
guys are asking my question here
is when are we going to see the return
of mad jim jasper's
that's what i want i want to see jim
jasper's come back i want to see him and
i want to see the fury i want to see
that because the fury we should i don't
know if we ever did no mega biano mega
level video on the fury
i think we did and if we did uh you know
the my my guys will have it down in the
description the fury is
wildly overpowered right he's insanely
powerful it's it's kind of nuts but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an
end uh if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
peace
do
uh
uh
uh